Hello喽hello喽，
猜我们在哪儿？
我们在深圳机场，
我要去海南，
去海南干嘛呢？
因为海南有一个肖博会，
是国家级的哦，
是海南封关之后的第一届，
应该算是封关之后的首届消博会，
差不多得有60多个，
呃，
全世界各个地方的国家和地区要来展示他们的商品，
然后我们也国家也是层层选拔了好多优秀的产品，
吃的喝的用的就是化妆品啊什么的都有，
应有尽有，
我们这次就想去看看有什么好东西，
一条过走走走走走，
我们什么时候出差，
因为活动到几号来着，
13号到18号你收拾一下带什么呢？
万一碰到粉丝怎么办呢？
那我们是不是要准备点买点东西，
要不把我们的样品给他们带上吧，
3块9毛9的那个眼罩，
哎，
刚才多钱的那个刮眉刀，
还有那个什么，
有人说让把你的书带着那。
就变色啊，
那个太沉了，
我们还有什么样品眉笔液防晒防晒了啊，
防晒挺贵的，
我防防晒一个划下来50多块钱呢，
那我们再看看吧，
看有没有一些小礼物，
可以到时候去水杯看一下啊，
可以去试重试一下，
因为最近都开始天气热了，
带一点方便一点的衣服，
结果发现你怎么都是五颜六色的衣服，
对呀，
我喜欢各种各样的颜色，
白色的衬衫比较大方一点，
拿一件好看吗？
这个比较简单大方一点哦，
嗯，
这个牛仔裤这一件哇，
这件格子衫他们好喜欢呢，
搞错了吧，
是另外一件啊，
我们去华山北市这件吗？
不是这件，
这是我刚买的，
我以为这件是他们要的，
试一下吧，
这个颜色应该也挺上镜的，
这是不是今天穿反了那件，
这件衣服好多姐妹挺喜欢的，
但也有人说我穿着可土了。
紧的假好吓，
有点吓人啊，
嗯，
这个白色的一个，
哎呦，
这件，
这是我斥巨资买的，
300多块钱买的，
一直没有机会穿，
不知道什么场合穿好看吗？
嗯嗯，
要不去了，
再买新衣服吧，
姐，
咱放不下了，
那买点裤衩子，
买点袜子，
买点内衣没了，
化妆品拿一点，
要把你的哑铃拿着，
哑铃有有，
呃，
6斤的，
你不会每天晚上就在这儿磕长头吧？
对呀，
我就在这儿啊，
对对，
动一个这个动作，
好，
这个动作可以把你手臂练习，
我们不是要出拾行李吗？
杀，
是啊，
你不是在给我们展示得拿了个面膜面霜。
我都想起来了啊，
我的水先拿我的口红，
牙刷牙膏，
还这个也眼部按摩姐你洗手台上这个指甲感觉挺好用的呀，
这个我就平时把手机放这儿，
我就在这儿护肤啊什么的，
这样就可以自拍，
呃，
自拍，
而且可以跟大家说哪个好用哪个不好用，
直接吸在这里，
然后就可以拍视频了啊，
你怎么你在车上也要帮助个保证是我是顾客，
防晒一定要做到死，
护肤部最重视的就是防晒护理啊，
化学霜擦防晒霜，
打伞防晒做好了真的就不容易老在车上都要打伞做防晒，
天呐，
哎。
姐姐那阵高被重点检查，
买充电宝一定要买3C的，
我刚才有一个很小的那种口红充电宝就带不走在那儿了。
姐遇到了一个粉丝，
头一次遇到oko OK,
然后每次都是粉丝遇到我们的时候云淡风轻，
然后我们自己激动了好久，
姐，
这个适合你出行，
哎，
你把人家路走了，
骑上我心爱的小摩托，
他永远不会堵车，
小小失路，
再来骑上我心爱的小摩托，
它永远不会堵。
嗯，
新哥的是哪一个大师？
哈喽哈喽，
我们要去出差啦，
到海南啦，
我们去吃点好吃的吧，
走，
速冻鸡，
买个椰子带我回家。